what's up guys i'm lisa foiles i'm so
excited to be here on gamespot and to
welcome you to analog a new weekly show
that's here to help you out so I'm sure
you know the feeling you find an amazing
game that completely sucks you in four
days and weeks and then it's over it's
just over and you're left with this
empty hole in your heart and you need
more game well good news I'm here to
fill your hole today we're talking
titanfall the amazing multiplayer
experience for the xbox one 360 MPC that
rodeo the gaming industry with insanely
fun combat parkouring and giant battling
mechs what more could you possibly ask
for maybe your pc can barely run
solitaire maybe you don't have an xbox
or maybe you've just played the crap out
of it and need a change of pace either
way we've got you covered here are games
similar to tighten frog
action a big downside of multiplayer on
the Xbox is not only do left by the game
but you also have to pay the monthly
xbox live subscription fee just to play
it online this ends up being kind of a
hefty price to see robots punch each
other in the face so how about a
free-to-play option for your pc try
hawkins what makes hawking like
titanfall well for one it's mex battling
mechs and glorious first-person
multiplayer different macs require
different play styles with perks
including jump jet fuel and active camo
these big bundles of bolts are actually
quite agile keeping the game pretty
fast-paced which is a much-loved element
of titanfall and hey it may not be
realistic but I would rather be a
frolicking robot than a slow 80s he
gettin taken down by a bunch of fuzzy
walks yes that is just embarrassing
here's what's different it's free to
play you can spend real money on
upgrades and such but the game itself
costs nothing plus you get to spend more
time inside your mech instead of calling
one down from the sky only to climb in
and get ambushed 10 seconds later
tyne fo was this huge blockbuster so
it's a hype and the gimmicks of time
fall make you roll your eyes then you'll
be happy to hear that Hawking is a more
serious experience I found that it takes
a bit more focus but don't let that
scare you don't get sucked into the idea
that Hawkin is the hipster to titan
falls bro cause they're both awesome and
playing titanfall might actually make
you appreciate hawking more alright say
you ignore the taunting of Eric Cartman
and stuck with Sony in the console war
the only problem is titanfall is a
microsoft exclusive and now you feel
like you're missing out well if star
hook for the ps3 got past you you might
want to give another look starhawk is
third person and like titanfall has a
multiplayer that lets you utilize mechs
plus it shares the same fun fast pace
but this game gives you more for your
money with a single player campaign set
in an outer space frontier it's got that
space cowboy feel these mechs or Hawks
let you fly which is great for
multiplayer as are the added vehicles
you get hoverbikes jeeps and tanks plus
you have this ability to call down
buildings from the sky to act as
barriers for tactical creativity my only
complaint is that the single-player
campaign really does not prepare you at
all for multiplayer you pretty much just
gets shoved out of the nest and try not
to get your head blown off lastly if the
park chorong in titanfall really appeal
to you you know running along rooftops
and sprinting on the sides of walls then
you will love Mirror's Edge no
multiplayer no max no running and
gunning but that might be a desired
change of pace Mirror's Edge puts you in
the first person shoes of faith whose
job it is to run sensitive documents
from sender to receiver in an oppressed
corrupt world no more flying by the seat
of your pants like you do in titanfall
mirrors edge is all about precision in a
methodical trial and error experience
you pick up speed as you string together
moves it's as beautiful dance when you
hit your stride end of frustrating
choppy mess when you screw up which you
will
there is combat though not traditional
FPS with a perfectly timed button push
faith extracts guns from the blues with
head grabs knees to the face and karate
chops there are a lot of creative ways
to take down enemies without ever firing
a shot it's a method of defense it seems
to fit faiths personality you can kind
of tell she's not really in this for a
fight though I bet if she had access to
around Titan she would totally
reconsider that as for met games i would
love to recommend the original steel
battalion just to make you hunt down
that massive 40 button controller but i
will be nice don't do that leave me a
comment and let me know which games you
think are similar to titanfall and now
that it's been a few weeks are you still
playing it are you still hooked let us
know and hit me up on twitter at lisa
foiles and i will see you next week for
another episode of analog rodeo on